if you have young children in your
family try this experiment
ask them what the plural of the word dog
is
they'll likely stare at you wide-eyed
for a few seconds
not having any idea what you're talking
about now
say this pretend i have one dog
if i get another one i have to
the moment they catch on i'll bet you
anything that they'll smile and shout
dogs so what happened there
technically the two questions had the
same exact answer
how can a child so easily produce a
plural noun when he or she has
no idea what the heck a plural even
means
hi my name is luca from lucranpeda.com
and you might be surprised
but the answer holds the key to the
absolute best way you
or anyone else can learn the grammar of
a foreign language
the inability of a child to use
grammatical plurals
without even knowing what plural means
is not an anomaly
ask the child verbatim to conjugate a
verb or identify
the direct object of a sentence and
they'll be
equally at a loss even though they do
both of these things
hundreds of times a day so again we're
compelled to ask
how can a child speak english or italian
or polish or
whatever language fluently without the
knowledge of grammar terms
and even more annoyingly if a child can
speak a language
natively without all this complicated
grammar study
then why do i a functioning adult
struggle with a language after spending
countless hours with my head
in grammar books the answers to these
questions reveal the existence of two
completely different forms of grammar
learning
one which is highly effective and
another one that is
highly ineffective in most cases the
first form which children use
is called implicit learning and the
second which adults use
and after suffer through is called
explicit learning
to learn implicitly means learning
through exposure and
interaction engaging in meaningful
communication
within a positive emotional environment
this is what children do
and what they do constantly for ears
on end to learn explicitly means
learning through lots of direct
instructions
lectures textbook readings and
convoluted written explanations
and this is what young adults and adults
do in high school or
college and beyond explicit learning is
practically the exact
opposite of implicit learning and the
results show this especially
when learning skills like languages now
you might not be convinced
implicit learning and explicit learning
might sound like
fancy technical terms used to describe
what is essentially the same thing
learning but no trust me the difference
between
implicit learning and explicit learning
is huge
and it's something scientists have
directly observed for themselves
in action back in 1953 a man known to
scientists hm
not to be confused with clothing giant h
m had much of his brain removed
to to health issues in particular he
lost his amygdala and hippocampus
along with a few other key brain
components as a result
hm had no memory of facts he could eat
breakfast and then forget it happened
five minutes later
he could have had a whole conversation
with someone and then
soon forget they ever existed despite
this
hm could remember some things
not facts not events but skills one
could teach him to navigate a maze or
trace a pattern on a page while looking
in a mirror or
and he'd get better and faster at it
every time
he would not remember ever learning that
maze or tracing that pattern
and but something in his brain retained
the practice he could still develop
skills just
as normal brain people could though he
would not consciously be able to
recognize that he's performed
those skills before to put his
succinctly hm could learn implicitly but
not explicitly he had no mind for facts
and events but asked him to practice a
task again and again and he could
improve at it just like you
and i would the story of him helped
scientists learn that implicit
and explicit learning are entirely
different processes that occur in
separate parts of the brain as human
beings we lean on both
at different points and sometimes
together but they still remain
separate from one another okay back to
the present
i've shared with you the story of hm so
you can start thinking about your brain
in terms of
implicit and explicit learning how you
use each
defines your language learning results
so
what does this imply for you and the way
you learn grammar
first let's briefly discuss the ways you
can use implicit learning to more
effectively learn the grammar of your
own
target language one massive exposure you
need to expose yourself to your target
language as much
as you can the more exposure you get to
texts audio
and video the better read and listen to
as much
authentic language as you can find two
comprehensible input
when you choose material for your
massive exposure start with things you
can
mostly understand this seems obvious but
it is not
if you engage in content that you
understand little and which has no other
means of support
like list of vocab at the end or
translation or
some grammar notes then drop it free
meaningful interaction with human beings
just as the early experiences of
children are filled with countless
interactions with parents and loved ones
you should try to fill your language
learning with meaningful
time spent with friends tutors and
language partners
nowadays it's not too difficult to make
new connections online so even if you
can't hang out in person
you have the option to connect on skype
or zoom for that matter
four live as many experiences as
possible
if you want to learn a language in a
natural way you need to live
the language this means that after you
spent a while
hitting the books you should go out and
try to use and experience
the language in the real world travel
attend meetups go hiking go to the
movies try to experience as much of life
as you can
but through your target language five
get emotional
emotions play a key role in the way we
remember things even grammar rules
make sure that most of what you do in
your target language consists of things
that you find fun
interesting and emotionally impactful
now
let's take a look at what you can do
when it comes to explicit
learning one use grammar books but only
as a reference
grammar books are not meant to be read
cover to cover consult them rarely and
only for quick clarification
don't let yourself get bogged down by
technical details
and if you can take notes in your own
words for increased memorization of
finer details
two practice language awareness most
people are not aware of how they speak
words they choose the mistakes they make
and even their facial features or body
language
when speaking developing awareness of
the grammar mistakes you make
while you produce language is key if you
want to improve
three get feedback while you can figure
out a lot for yourself through practice
and occasional glances at a grammar book
our capacity to notice things has its
limits it is
critical to consult native speakers for
feedback on your mistakes
because there are even mistakes you
don't know you're making
four implement the feedback receiving
feedback is not enough
you need to implement it in order to
improve how many times have you received
some correction and then continue to
make the same mistake
over and over and over again that's
because your will to hone your grammar
was not strong enough you need to
constantly strive to avoid repeating the
same mistakes
you'll fail at that often sure but the
more you practice
implementing feedback the better you'll
speak
a final important note some people think
that you don't need to learn grammar at
all
throw the books away stay away from any
grammar explanation just rely on
comprehensible input
i don't believe this is the best way to
go about things
i think that as an adult you need a
certain amount of explicit
grammar explanations an amount that
depends primarily on the language
distance between your native language
and your target language the closer two
languages
are the more features they have in
common
an italian learning spanish might learn
the language without
needing to crack open a grammar book
simply because
spanish and italian are so similar an
italian learning japanese on the other
hand
might need to spend considerably more
time learning both implicitly and
explicitly about how japanese grammar
works
considering the languages differ greatly
in terms of syntax
vocab and morphology and one more
observation
the longer the distance between your
mother tongue and the target language
the longer it will take you for you to
assimilate those
grammar patterns in a reliable way no
matter how smart and diligent you are
there will be many many times when
you'll forget a grammar pattern or
two or ten this is inevitable
even if you read and re-read your notes
a dozen times as a language learner it
is extremely
important to understand that this is the
moment in the marathon
where you have to show great endurance
to succeed
otherwise you can easily lose motivation
the reality is
as an adult you need both implicit and
explicit learning you need to know the
rules of the game and you need to
practice and play the game
both things mutually interact and
reinforce each other
and come to think of it the arc of your
learning should follow
that of a child as well all educated
native speakers have gone through a
phase of implicit learning at home and
then
a phase of explicit learning at school
they first learn to speak the language
and then they learn about the language
in school
as a rule of thumb try to divide your
implicit and explicit learning time
according to the pareto principle
eighty percent of time should be spent
learning implicitly while the other
twenty percent of your time should be
spent
learning explicitly so to wrap up
it's important to stress that human
beings absorb language
most effectively through a process
called implicit learning
the opposite process called explicit
learning is effective for memorizing
facts and events
but less so for developing skills like
language
as adults we should strive to learn
grammar mostly implicitly
but we should also use your explicit
learning tools to help us bridge the gap
when necessary focus on learning from
raw authentic language for the bulk of
your learning
but then crack open a grammar book in
those rare moments where you need a
small push
to help you understand a concept if
you'd like to learn more about implicit
and explicit learning be sure to check
the description box for a link
to my blog where i've shared a great
article
on the subject as always thanks for
watching and if you enjoyed this video
be sure to like subscribe and
hit the notification bell for lots more
great content
to come
[Music]
you